[Music]
our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
really far greater than what divides us
this morning the unlikely path toward
finding family
a homeless man panhandling at a transit
station discovered a new life thanks to
some people who gave him a chance our
San Francisco station that's KPIX
started following this story last year
those of cook-up KPIX is here in studio
57 to show us to tell us all about it
she says it's never too late for a
second chance Elizabeth nice to see you
welcome to the table thank you for
having me good morning for decades Mick
Meyers lived his life on the streets he
had no one today he has a family thanks
to a sheriff's deputy and a private eye
who gave Mick a new beginning I've been
living a life as alone as a person can
possibly be a loner
that's how Mick Meyers describes himself
no kids never married the only love he
knew his adopted mother
[Music]
homeless for 30 years Mick gets by
playing for tips at a BART station in
the Bay Area and panhandling along the
highway
that's where sheriff's deputy Jacob
swole well caught up with him last year
he warned mix several times to stop the
next step was to issue a citation and
instead of issuing a citation he asked
him a question I asked him what's it
gonna take to get you off the street
because at that point I realized me
writing him a citation it's not gonna
help him at all as I got closer I
realized he was a senior citizen that's
a four year 67 how come you're not on
Social Security and says well I can't
get it because I can't even get an ID I
got nobody to help me and he says well
you got somebody to help you now even
with small Wells resources at the
Alameda County Sheriff's Department
it took three separate trips to the DMV
for Mick to get an identification card
it's made me realize that we need to
utilize more resources that are
available to us to help others and if we
can do that we're doing the right thing
as law enforcement officers small Wells
persistence paid off Mick is now on
Medicaid and has applied for Social
Security benefits it makes me feel good
that there is actually people in the
world who acknowledge me because very
few people have before but mixed fresh
start was just beginning private
investigator mark as khun's volunteers
for miracle messages a non-profit
devoted to reconnecting the homeless
with their loved ones when he learned of
Mick's story he wanted to help out it
was thrilling very thrilling to find
this information using the little
information provided Askins was able to
find Mick's birth mother Polly living
roughly 250 miles away in Eureka
California
she was just the length just to see him
and to talk to him and to you know a
true mother's love it was just it was
beautiful I found one more person to
live Polly didn't have an easy life
either after leaving her husband
she was a teenage mom struggling to
support three kids Mick was sick and
needed surgery so when he was two years
old Polly gave him up for adoption to
her mother's friend who could afford to
get him the help he needed
I feel the sadness that he's had to go
through this to feel so alone but at the
same time I'm proud of him because no
matter what happened like me he's a
survivor
deputies swim well and Mark Askins
arranged for Mick to fly to meet the
mother who gave him up sixty-five years
ago
Polly's home is now full of family ready
to embrace Mick he didn't just get a mom
he got a whole family and they all
descended in might one day to have you
back puts a piece of my heart back and
it means the world to me you're a part
of my life now and I hope you will
always will want to be for Mick the
future may be uncertain but the past is
finally resolved after a lifetime of
waiting but I thought never would happen
happened a 67 year old man meets his 85
year old mother who died thought that
something like this couldn't happen to
anybody let alone be
[Music]
poly has invited Nick to come live with
her and her husband in Eureka
but Mick is hesitant to move away from
the area where he's really spent his
whole life for now he's working on
getting a car and promises to go back
and visit as often as possible I don't
even remember the last time I seen a
story like no you come to the table to
make a smile in each other they did I
mean this whole group of characters is
amazing they found each other and the
friendship that all of them have it's
pretty heartwarming Wow and they found
it in a place called Eureka that's right
that's thank you Elizabeth